quand tu fais au cover au sabbat c'est
pareil tu prend dans la gueule mon frère
c'est pas de ta famille peut-être cru
reconnaître à un joueur comme star dans
la grille pourquoi vous ne connaissez
pas et je connais les chèques qu'on se
connaît bien on peut le débat là dessus
mais c'est vrai que voilà nagui moi je
dis franchement c'est pas de sa faute il
cartonne tout le temps il progresse
arrive à tourner la page pour pas qu'il
y ait plusieurs suites de tôle il faut
arrêter on va voir comment vous allez
faire sur ces news ou m'attaque je le
dis allez tout de suite vous a parlé de
johnny puisque une comédie musicale sur
johnny est en préparation et nafa bien
le cas co auteur de la comédie musicale
sur johnny qui va nous en parler parce
que il ya plein de questions là dessus
c'est parti c'est la sphère johnny on a
des images où pareil on a un point
johnny c'est parti
c
arthur vient du bold as dis moi que tom
cruise vélo mais j'adore franchement
comment sa maman fabien alors la comédie
mais j'ai quatre show johnny qui va
arriver qui est en préparation elle a
exactement et il paraît que voilà ça
pose beaucoup de problèmes cette affaire
alors vous avez été contacté pour écrire
la caméra moi j'ai été contacté pour
pour l'écriture évidemment parce qu'ils
connaissent mes livres j'ai fait cette
livre sur johnny hallyday
thomas dernier qui rappelle l'histoire
des chansons avec son accord d'ailleurs
à l'époque puisqu'il était sorti trois
mois avant sa disparition
et puis et puis ils ont en projet de
faire un spectacle tributes sur les
chansons de johnny 24 comme c'est un
classique en ce moment il ya énormément
de spectacles sur johnny qui tourne pas
du tout les sosies après sosie de johnny
hallyday qui tourne en ce moment en
france mais cela autour d'eux ils ont
les plannings rempli parce que un moment
donné depuis sa disparition les gens ont
envie de lui racheter et donc mais bon
quand vous dites vous avez été contacté
on sait qu'ils vous le producteur qui
s'appelle david michel a donc rien à
voir avec sébastien farran ah non non
non mais sébastien farran qui est un
très grand manager qui s'occupait des
affaires de johnny sur les cinq derniers
des années de sa vie jusqu'au 5 décembre
2017 date disparition de johnny puisque
maintenant nous sommes aujourd'hui tous
suspendus
ah oui à la décision de justice qui sera
prise le 22 novembre à 100 cette année
22h22 de ventes cette année à savoir qui
va représenter finalement est ce que
c'est les etats-unis qui avaient rang
avec laeticia et le droit américain a
soit ce sera le trust qui dirigera les
affaires de johnny hallyday
et puis si c'est le droit français à
partir de là c'est
eh bien ce sera alors à il y aura cinq
héritiers si c'est le droit français
c'est à dire ses quatre enfants et sa
dernière épouse sa dernière alors c'est
très clair donc expliquer ce que les
personnels doit donner son accord pour
que le show soit lancé la comédie
musicale ça c'est important
mais s'il est si laeticia et la
représentante de johnny hallyday à
partir du 22 novembre
ouais oui avec le trust de quoi ils
doivent attendre alors sinon elle ne
peut pas interdire le fait qu'on chante
des chansons de johnny
sauf dans trois cas sexuelles politiques
ou religieux c'est à dire une chanson
c'est à dire si par exemple on n'utilise
que je t'aime pour un site de rencontres
ah ouais on sent que là il ya
détournement de l'oeuvre d'accord si
c'est al qaïda qui va prendre comme
générique je te promets c'est interdit
ouais et c'est le parti socialiste prend
aux marines comme générique pareille
politique religieux ou sexuelles on n'a
pas le droit à partir du moment où l'on
chante sa chanson refrain couplet
couplet-refrain personne peut interdire
une chanson république dont il ya eu des
précédents comme ça dont des pouvait
faire le spectacle sont là corps de
laetitia oui c'est un tribut si on
chante
d'accord ça existe en ce moment il
allait raconter toute l'histoire de
johnny de ses très longs kg pas encore
sur quel où on va partir là on est
vraiment dans les bauges des choses mais
ça va me faire c'est sur cette comédie
musicale sur johnny alors je vais vous
dire sa lancée sur ce projet avant la
décision de justice va cesser c'est à
dire moi je si on s'appuie sur james
blunt qui était mort le 25 décembre 2006
c'est un joueur qui a été enterré qui a
été enterré le 10 mars 2007 ses dires il
est resté quand même en chambre froide
trois mois et demi ah ouais ouais et les
enfants non mais c'est important de
pratiquer il alors désisté par lui et
que finalement non mais c'est à dire est
important ils ont mis deux ans et demi
pour se mettre d'accord les vérités y
avait six enfants et une épouse une
épouse qui n'était j'étais encore marié
que son premier mari alors qu'elle était
veuve du chanteur est scellée mort de
rire donc si on prend le dossier de ce
roi de la soul
sahamies quand même deux ans et demi je
pense que johnny ça
insomnia la perle je pense que nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est important de savoir c'est pas
la première affaire n'est pas traîné
entre deux ans et demi on va dire et
disant alors est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est normal en moi juste arrêté et des
questions juste les cherry est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est normal qu'on
fasse comme the musical sur johnny west
coast swing c'est surfait 1 voilà sur le
truc dit la vérité
moi je trouve que c'est pour vous
pardon pardon ça vient mais moi je
trouve que c'est un peu tôt il est en
même temps qu'ils écrivent c'est un
début ouais mais même jeu par le
problème de de l'héritage n'est pas
encore réglé c'est une famille qui se
déchire encore johnny vient à peine
d'être enterrée est ce qu'on peut pas le
laisser un tout petit peu trop maquillée
et éventuels juste à valerio sait jamais
finalement les ayants droit qui décident
souvent c'est à la demande du public
l'aco savoir sinon on va bien on m'a
bien je vais juste si on va en france
par exemple en ce moment à l'heure où on
parle ce soir ya peut-être entre cinq et
dix spectacles aux jeunes hallyday en
france
alors non les anti-chasse paris vous
n'êtes pas au courant mais je peux vous
dire c'est une romance en province et
quand on allait voir les clubs allaient
voir les discothèques à les voir tous
les tous les lieux les plages etc
raconte pas l'histoire des dinosaures
des gens qui chantent mais ça va très
vite mais j'ai dit que c'est une pépite
un geste d'un tri but c'est pas qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui vous choque donc fait
qu'on va lui rendre hommage
quand je dis je suis ambitieux plein en
finisse et je me bats on va lui rendre
hommage au même contenu justement il ya
tellement eu de bons gars était
retournée là au contraire va venir à sa
musique et lui rendre hommage à travers
un spectacle qui leur est actuellement
sur l'héritage c'est anecdotique parce
qu'avant tout c'est une oeuvre musicale
jouée sa plage publique à des millions
de gens en france soit environ
ça reste un artiste un chanteur avant 3
j'ai envie de voir un hommage à jo
comédie musicale excusez moi vous et
matthieu delormeau
ah non pardon pour moi serons honnêtes
fabien 8 pas c'est à la demande du
public jean louis vous êtes havrais à un
grand généreux c'est pour faire quand
même malgré tout beaucoup d'argent
surtout dans une comédie musicale
et c'est sur le perron vivier ici nous x
non mais je trouve que ses soeurs fait
un peu trop tôt pour le moment sur une
histoire un petit peu lycée paul rey sur
la mort de quelqu'un ça donc c'est pour
faire du pognon et comme il joue
non je vais vous répondre parce que
c'est pas du tout pour faire plaisir au
public
en effet d'écrire ça rend en europe il
ya par exemple 43 sosie d'elvis presley
qui tourne et les vingt-sept sur l'autre
et en soit cinquante ans après non non
non non ils ont commencé à la
disparition des artistes 77 ont dit oui
je peux vous dire que c'est c'est pas
vous qui allez décider le top départ a
bien sûr tout à fait un documentaire sur
jean anixton maggio bateau s'il va se
faire d'argent
regardez et écoutez tom cruise
la précision est ce que ça veut dire que
la comédie qui narre un carré de ligue 2
puis vous avez votre quotidien vous la
péter un peu les jeux parce qu'ils
aiment la main c'est super c'est le prix
parce qu'elle est donnée bien ton nom
oui moi je suis très déçu par vous
fabien je voulais toit très déçu par
quelqu'un tous les soirs mais là
franchement je vois pas pourquoi vous
vous lancer là dedans c'est de
l'opportunisme pas moi alors pas du tout
intéressé les droits christie qui sont
au tribunal en ce moment on sait pas qui
sont adoubés fans annoncé quoi vous
serez disques continuent à placer la
radio en ce moment je suis désolé de
vous dire
et les hommages qui à la télévision et
l'humour que les émissions spéciales les
ayants droits touchent des droit les
auteurs les compositeurs en ce moment
même si ça va juste à vous